un enfant casse une assiette à la
cantine et son collège envoie une
facture de 3,28 € à ses parents qu'il
paye en pièce de 1 centime cette
histoire elle se passe au collège
Léonard de Vinc situé à vitril les reins
dans le département de la Marne la
semaine dernière pendant l'heure du
repas un garçon de 12 ans casse une
assiette sans le faire exprès selon ses
déclaration c'est la première fois que
ça lui arrive mais l'établissement a
tout de même voulu demander aux parents
un dédommagement pour la casse l'élève
de 5e repart donc chez lui avec une
facture de 3,28 € à donneré à ses
parents dans le journal L'Union le
principal du collège explique avoir
simplement appliqué le règlement dont
les parents auraient cononnaissance
quand ils inscrivent leur enfants à la
restauration scolaire il ajoute que la
vaisselle cassée quotidiennement aurait
un coût important et c'est pour cela
qu'il est logique de demander aux
parents de payer il précise aussi nous
ne sommes pas le seul établissement à le
faire comme le geste de l'enfant serait
involontaire le beau-père trouve cette
décision incompréhensible on parle d'un
gamin de 12 ans qui casse une assiette
pour la première fois sans le faire
exprès je trouve ça mesquin ça
représente quoi une assiette à quoi
correspond exactement cette somme de
3,28 € même si la décision ne passe pas
les parents ont fini par payer la
facture mais avec uniquement des pièces
d'un centime soit 328 pièces rouges